c'est donc la journée illégal journée
mondiale de la presse aussi par la poste
aux labos touche pas à ma poste ce soir
donc forcément on a reçu des du courrier
téléspectateurs oui j'espère h 30
j'avais un accessoire mais on a quand
même mis on a mis un gros coup dur le
bon du tout sur le sur le ja l'orissa
date devenue dépendante de gagner alors
j'ai pu te fais des petites et des
petits cours et donc on va ouvrir non je
dois à a été bien fait c'était aussi
devrait courir c'est non c'est pas d'la
alors même temps regarde alors chers
benjamin hier plus de la moitié de vos
chroniqueurs dormait sur le plateau du
coucher à 19h07 que ce soir on va vivre
la même le même enfer dites moi ça très
vite je suis là deux doigts de mettre un
support essais signés loïc rooney
monchal oui ça nous croyez moi j'espère
qu'ils vont se réveiller avant 19h cette
salle est effectivement assez compliqué
alors à l'aréna de claudine de l'île aux
laudine de lille il ya des comptes rien
alors c'est une lettre pour qui ça va de
plus en plus vite toujours bons mots
bonjour mon mari mon mari est fou de
christine kelly et cette situation ne
peut plus dures jamais avec les hommes
mariés
merci de ne plus mettre à tenter
ça
alors je vais vous dire déjà arrivé à
plusieurs reprises des femmes qui me
disent mon mari et vous de vous alors
que ça soit clair jamais avec un homme
marié
ça ne m'intéresse pas c'est à vue le
mari encore même si vraiment vraiment et
je vous dis j'ai déjà sauvé des couples
comme ça en gros sa coupe
non mais par exemple où le mec bien
voilà je renvoie chez lui je veux dire
ça sert à rien à quoi ça sert vraiment
ou après
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais dit ça merci beaucoup mais bien
chaud mais la joie vous fasse on vous
dit qu'on parle de sexe tout de suite
derrière j'en ai commencé par ça et le
bruit parce que je sais que vous aimez
bien on rêvait bien sûr mais faire ça
à l'approché de l'être alors aux mecs
foulard mais alors là où l'attend cher
monsieur castel dire voilà je me permets
de vous écrire pour savoir si sans
savoir où en sont les préparatifs du
mariage de fatou et vélos et de
l'autocar alors ces crises de limoges
alors ça avance bien
l'autre poker c'est donc vous je me suis
reconnu tout de suite en france bien
bassam à sa réponse bien honnêtement ça
arrange bien bas et je peux pas vous
dire plus je fais il reste à trouver un
lieu et une date tout le reste est fixé
58e
non mais sérieusement vous rendez compte
on a commencé cette aventure avec cyril
d'akwaya c'est à dire il ya quatre ans
et ridha investis dont il a fait une
séquence de l'argent y est passé il est
quand même est très pointilleux sur les
dépenses il vous a offert une bague
fatou est venu en plaques tories à la
foule avait fait une déclaration à
genoux oui elle a dit oui oui et trois
ans après y'a rien mais ça avance bien
ce que vous pouvez lire plus mais ça
n'avance pas merci vraiment vraiment
c'est l'amour fou ça avance très bien il
ya juste quelques petits préparatifs
mais franchement alors très mauvais
lancer alors on peut lancer n y crois au
mariage de gilles mais non meilleur a
dit à quiconque un mariage de gilles on
va voir si les gens croient ou non à des
histoires
moi je vous dis franchement je n'y crois
plus mais moi je préfère me marier une
fois bien que trois ou quatre fois match
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
venir dire nous dira mieux vaut pas moi
je préfère réussi à mon divorce à wittes
raté mon mariage
quand on rate son mariage c'est bien de
réussir son divorce voilà voilà
c'est que je me posais la question quand
même parce que moi si on me demande en
mariage le soir j'ai trouvé une date
j'ai trouvé un lieu à oui je trouve et
il est déjà tout préparé c'est pour ça
qu'on vous demande pas mariés vous avez
des enfants et vit qu'une femme
mais depuis combien de temps aux depuis
longtemps ses 22 25 ans mais c'est pas
le moment de faire une demande là à
aller pour mariage c'est pas pour
mariages n'ont pas bronché
tu peux faire tellement dans sa vie
c'est ça vous fait peur
non je ne peux pas je suis pas pour ah
oui j'avais demandé en plus qu'à écouter
si mal à vraiment vous nous regardez un
petit sms vous m'envoyez 1
voyez pas de ses très bas et mariage
sans toi je vais me débrouiller sans que
je vous en bas je pars sans toi parce
que j'ai pas envie de divorcer trois
fois non plus bombay 510 adore soit on
est bon on est où vous sexuellement
parlant ça c'est tranquille au but être
seul que mal accompagné
tiens ça fait vous êtes très bien cela
paraît très épanouie c'est commencer il
se passe jamais rien si si mais pas
d'officialisation ouais mais c'est à
dire buzz oui ia mais on avait il ya il
ya des rencontres et des très jolies
rencontres mais c'est paillade mais une
madame guény en imagination n'ont pas
encore dans un monsieur guy ni non plus
ample à bientôt
vous avez vous avez un chat g2g j'avais
une chatte
oui c'est le meilleur maximini ça il
avait une chatte il a perdu plus que si
elle était très mignonne a déboulé
paribas ce qu'elle est elle est au ciel
au ciel des chats les chances cette vie
cette vie cf
neuf vies merci
vous avez vous êtes sûr que c'est un
homme vit très bien une bonne info wesh
par webcast ah ouais je casta e watch à
toi je vous écris car j'ai une question
pour bernard montiel
c'est une vacherie je le sens je le vois
ici rigole s'il ne parlait pas des
points soleil je suis jamais allée de ma
vie mais non non non non je trouve site
en question merci merci mathilde nîmes
c'est des questions qui vraiment est
essentielle oui c'est ça c'est vous
rigolez alors wesh casta je répète un je
vous écris car j'ai une question pour
ben avant-hier à quoi servez-vous
ce que je peux répondre en deux mots
[Rires]
j'allais le dire ça arrive vraiment à
dire non je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
comment ça se fait que ça fait 35 ans
télévision 35 vicié oui je les fais deux
ans oui oui et oui si tu as aidé les
gens à aller chez les gens non virtuelle
piste et si elle avait trompé et toucher
les draps ccu minla ouais non je me suis
renseigné passait par hasard me suis
renseigné en tout bien tout honneur ou
jours maintenant il ya plus de mariages
payer plus de divorce pour faute
monsieur plus tard divorce tout court il
faut réhabiliter les huissiers il n'ya
pas que ces constats d'adultère donc que
je viens d'évoquer un huissier par
exemple un dégât des eaux très bien
content que le mec louise d'un dégât des
eaux tata le papier tu te fais un bon
seigneur sith harbig a de la gueule ça
mais on a dit on essaie on avait annoncé
au début il y avait un problème mais
elle a une qui a mal tourné est ce que
je peux faire a constaté que ça a foiré
pas
oui bien sûr l'avarice important avant
après bien sûr il peut se retourner
contre le médecin d'ailleurs on devrait
le faire d'ailleurs avant de se faire
opérer d'ailleurs je lance un couteau
avant après ah oui j'ai dansé me dit oui
à mal bien nommé premier métier avec
vidéo gag 10 millions de spectateurs
en même temps donnez moi je vais quand
même dire un truc c'est que c'est vrai
certains anciens se gargarise de leur
grand score à la télévision enfin faire
16 millions quoi y'a trois chaînes
c'est par ces mots que ça si c'est
aujourd'hui oui l'avenir et 21 il avait
importé le concept de vidéo gag des
états unis non mais c'est bien pour toi
mais vous l'avez produits toi non non
j'ai pas produit
c'est ce lébisey dit non c'est pas
attendez concept de l'émission que
j'avais proposé à tf1 effectivement
c'est pas moi qui les produit en prendre
mais c'est moi qui ai eu l'idée m'est
donc ça ne va pas remonter beaucoup
d'oseille
mais non parce que je vais pas de
producteur joe avait enquillé moi j'veux
pas de personnel je tiens à vous dire
que j'adore votre émission
c'est beaucoup de chaleur je perds que
s'il revient demain encore en interne
est encore en vie est encore en fait
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce cas demain voilà il
ya en vidant pardon et dans son cas on
peut pardonner à doigts pour un tpb xxl
et j'ai eu des infos que je me suis
baladée forcément joué dans pas mal
ah oui c'est son clip ou kido d'un
chocolat je ne suis pas au groupe ce que
je comprends moi même je bouquine non
y'a du lourd
tremblay alors je tiens à vous dire que
j'adore votre émission vous avez dans
votre équipe christophe carrière à quoi
sert-il
ben si c'est pas loin j'étais pas loin
vous avez donc christophe carrière
pourtant vous ne parlez pas de cinéma
est ce que c'est parce qu'il est mauvais
c'est ornans vous bientôt
aurore de paris alors c'est vrai que à
leur buteur où on va parler c'est
maintenant voilà où va mal avec la
mention au conseil soit que ces lanceurs
d'armes on aura d'ailleurs la réserve
c'est ce qui sera sur le plateau avec
deux comédiennes remarquable et c'est un
film événement croyez moi c'était un
film fort c'est un film un film d'action
activement engagés incroyable alors oui
pourquoi pas c'est à dire que quand on
parle de film que je n'aime pas on se
fait on va on préfère que je sois pas là
voilà wave n'est pas là pour cartonner
les invités donc voilà donc deux coups
je me mets en retrait est-ce que c'est
pas mal de sa parenthèse que meurt un
peu les films et émissions de cinéma
parce que quand on est avec quelqu'un
c'est humide mais là vous prêcher un
convaincu direct à hauterive et une
daube will vous prêcher un convaincu
m'avait parlé au dessus toi parce que
c'est les chaînes télé qui financent
donc ils sont pas trop chaud non plus
pour m marteau